a growing number of cyber security
experts blame
russia for a massive online attack
infiltrating
more than 40 u.s government agencies
president trump
is not accepting that in a weekend tweet
he blamed china
not russia without giving any evidence
and so far
he isn't taking any action in response
as paula reed reports the president is
even contradicting
his own secretary of state i think it's
the case that now
we can say pretty clearly that it was
the russians that engaged in this
activity
secretary of state mike pompeo this
weekend attributed a massive
cyber security breach to the kremlin but
just hours later
president trump downplayed the severity
of the incident and blamed
china tweeting there could also have
been a hit on
our ridiculous voting machines during
the election
president's unsubstantiated theory
defies the conclusions of experts inside
and outside
the government senator mitt romney said
the president has a blind spot when it
comes to russia
he doesn't want to recognize russia as
the problem they are
and the extraordinarily bad actor they
are on the world stage president-elect
joe biden's chief of staff signaled the
incoming administration
could respond with its own offensive
cyber actions
not just sanctions it's also steps and
things we could do
to degrade the capacity of foreign
actors to repeat
this sort of attack but the current
white house seems focused on fighting
the settled results of the 2020 election
on sunday the trump campaign filed an
appeal to the u.s supreme court
to reverse cases by pennsylvania's
highest court
the changed mail-in ballot laws and cbs
news has learned that in a meeting at
the white house
friday the president floated appointing
sydney powell
a controversial lawyer who has advanced
baseless conspiracy theories about the
election a special counsel
to investigate voter fraud in the 2020
races
president-elect biden's team has
declined to comment on that supreme
court appeal
but as the biden team continues to
transition here to the white house
today the president-elect will receive
his covid vaccination
vlad and we'll be watching paula reed
for us thank you paula